[Applaudissements]
des membres de plusieurs syndicats ont
manifesté devant l'assemblée nationale à
québec pour dénoncer le projet de loi
sur la réforme du régime de santé et de
sécurité au travail ça n'a pas empêché
le gouvernement d'adopter la loi à 12h30
aujourd'hui la nouvelle loi qui va
dorénavant couvrir tous les secteurs
d'activité économique elle va couvrir
davantage les maladies liées à la santé
psychologique avec une couverture
automatique pour les travailleuses
domestiques les stagiaires les
télétravailleurs et la maladie de
parkinson provoquées par l'exposition
aux pesticides sera maintenant couverte
tout comme la maladie de lyme est le
trouble de stress post traumatique avec
nos jambes ou les ministres du travail
de l'emploi et de la solidarité sociale
bonjour monsieur le ministre en soirée
lyon votre nouvelle loi était adopté on
a l'impression qu'elle fait l'unanimité
ont presque tout le monde est content
les partis d'opposition son compte les
syndicats sont contre le patronat est
contre pourquoi vous êtes allés de
l'avant quand même avec ce projet doit
pas écouter on peut faire ce projet de
loi doit maintenant qui est devenu une
loi l'a d'abord et avant tout pour les
travailleurs et les travailleuses du
québec où seulement pour les syndicats
les patrons bien évidemment faire une
loi dans le domaine des relations
travail l'a senti ces curés et ses
traits polaris mais monsieur fillion
faut que je vous mentionne qu'en 2019
il ya eu 107 mais l'accident de travail
260 par jour et 5 à travers 10 17
pendant cette année là il faut s'assurer
de protéger l'ensemble des travailleurs
tous les secteurs d'activité économique
et développer une culture de prévention
dans tous les milieux de travail c'est
ce qu'on fait avec cette loi mais ce
qu'il faut pas s'assurer d'avoir
l'adhésion des syndicats des
travailleuses et des travailleurs des
patrons de ceux qui vont devoir dit dans
les votes loi monsieur ministre oui vous
avez totalement raison d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'articles la majeure part une
cette loi lors ou sur des consensus qui
ont déjà été établis au comité
consultatif du travail de la main
d'oeuvre entre les leaders syndicaux et
patronaux à certains égards y avait pas
de consensus on s'est assuré de les
meilleures décisions dans l'intérêt des
travailleurs travailleuses et que tous
puissent bénéficier d'un programme de
prévention ou d'un plan d'action aucun
comité de santé sécurité d'un
représentant aussi pour les protéger les
syndicats disent votre projet de loi va
vise à déréglementer la protection des
travailleurs en réduisant toutes les
normes minimales en revenant
marginaliser la présence dans le
développement des programmes de
prévention des travailleurs est ce que
vous voulez mieux protéger les
travailleurs vont dire oui mais ce que
vous voulez surtout sauver de l'argent
non absolument faut savoir que ces deux
lois la loi santé sécurité et celle sur
les accidents du travail avait besoin
d'être dépoussiéré cd loi qui date de 40
ans et dans les lois antérieures il y
avait seulement certains c'est un
d'activité cannes avec était protégé
comme l'a dit lénine à l'anc dorénavant
tous les secteurs sont protégés et c'est
pas en diminuant les droits si on
s'assurera que dans les secteurs de la
santé services sociaux éducation
agriculture construction que tout le
monde bénéficie d'un mécanisme de
protection notre but c'est de diminuer
la fréquence et la gravité des accidents
de travail et pau essentiellement de
diminuer les coûts augmentent et
diminuent les coûts quand même parce que
dans votre analyse d'impact vous estimez
que la loi va permettre de réduire les
coûts de 1 milliard 5 à 4 milliards 300
millions d'ici dix ans donc est ce que
c'est on va faire ou séguéla sur les
indemnités versées
absolument si on diminue le nombre
d'accidents de travail c'est
inacceptable qu'on descend 7 mai
l'accident de travail par année au
québec notre régime étaient devenues
complètement désuet dépenses et avait
besoin d'être modernisée et c'est sûr
que les réformes en profondeur après
avec des lois qui datent de 40 ans ça
suscite des insatisfactions et quand on
s'assure de moderniser bailly c'est pas
tout le monde est totalement cette
bébête
satisfait parce que je vous le rappelle
tous les syndicats sont contre le
patronat est content vous avez fait
d'unanimité là dessus et aujourd'hui
syndicats disent il va avoir moins de
réunions des comités de prévention il va
avoir moins d'heures prévu pour les
comités de prévention c'est la cnss t
qui va décider c'est exact ça non c'est
pas tout à fait exact et comme vous le
savez quand on fait le commission
parlementaire on écoute les gros on a
fait des consultations particulières
j'ai eu des dialogues avec les leaders
syndicaux et les doigts patronaux
évidemment on s'est assuré que des
amendements à notre projet de loi est la
loi finalement répond aux intérêts c'est
sûr que on voudrait avoir plus d'un côté
on voudra avoir un peu moins de l'autre
côté mais je vous dis mon guide ultime
m'assurer que tous les travailleurs et
travailleurs soient protégés il avait
mentionné on a bonifié la liste des
maladies professionnelles résumé avec
les troupes de stress post traumatique
avec des cancers pour les pompiers
combattent la maladie de parkinson la
maladie de lyme et les travailleuses
doivent est écrit stagiaires il ya une
couverture qui est vraiment complet mais
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi les syndicats
ne sont pas d'accord et pourquoi le
patronat viens vous dire c'est trop
coûteuse et trop généreux c'est trop
lent pourquoi il n'y a pas d'adhésion à
ce que vous avez adopté aujourd'hui une
ministre bayonne une adhésion et un
consensus comme je vous mentionnais à
l'égard de plusieurs sections de cette
loi lors temps des syndicats que des
patrons encore une fois ce qui nous
guide s et la protection des
travailleurs et des travailleuses
là où il y avait pas de consensus à
l'occasion où il y syndicats demandaient
plus à certains égards et les patrons
demandait - et je pense qu'on a une loi
qui en équilibre et je pense que quand
on trouvait droite passage quand les
positions sont pas la risée on peut se
dire que c'est une loi qui est
respectueuse de ses objectifs meilleure
prévention diminution des accidents
déjudiciarisation les objectifs qu'on
avait au départ on se rend compte
maintenant il faut rallier tout le monde
que tout le monde soit ensemble et qu'on
m'ait week-end en oeuvre cette nouvelle
loi la baisse et ça mais ça aurait dû
être fait avant c'est pas avant avant
l'avantagé du projet doit vite ça a été
fait notre île comité consultatif du
travail de la merde elle a travaillé
main dans la main avec nous autres pour
faire des amendements on a consulté les
partenaires ok patronne route et disco
et tous les gros on verra à l'usure
réalisation merci monsieur voulait
d'avoir six essais pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit